Do you need to think strategically about
how you're going to organize,
manage,
and lead the enterprise to enable,
uh,
and adaptive,
resilient,
uh,
organization with high commitment and
the capacity to innovate and Change
Michael Beer,
professor emeritus at the Harvard
Business School and Chairman of true
point
leaders of these or of these
organizations have made and those who
aspire to,
to build these firms need to make a
number of critical choices.
The first and foremost choice is about
what is the purpose of the organization.
Uh,
is it to increase shareholder wealth and
stop there?
Or is it more than that?
Most high commitment,
high performance with high commitment,
high performance organizations have a
multistakeholder perspective.
They see their task as achieving
profitability.
That's very important.
It's essential for survival.
It's essential for,
uh,
for satisfying one of their critical
constituencies,
the investor,
uh,
but they also aspire to,
to create commitment,
not only investors,
but in customers and employees,
importantly and employees,
and in the,
and,
and to,
and to be concerned about the community
and society as,
as a,
as a whole.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so the choice of purpose and the choice
of,
of values that reflect that multi
stakeholder perspective is an,
is an essential first step,
uh,
in the development of affirm.
Uh,
without that philosophy.
Without that viewpoint,
uh,
you can get human resource departments
to do all kinds of things with policies
and practices,
you will not succeed.
Uh,
the second important choice they make is
about strategy.
A high commitment,
high performance organizations are
characterized by an increment,
illogical incrementalism as uh,
as a,
uh,
one of my one researcher once called it
logical incrementalism in their
strategic evolution over time.
Uh,
they don't,
uh,
they don't strike out into areas that
they are not,
they have any capabilities.
Then they stretched their capabilities,
they develop their capabilities and they
move into adjacent areas and grow that
way off core capabilities.
Uli Packard again would be a great
example.
Uh,
a core technology and test and
measurement led them to improve things
for the customer that led them to begin
to develop computer computer
capabilities were,
uh,
information processing capabilities
because that was part of building
better,
better tested measurement organizations.
And then they began to apply those same
ideas in a newer of a ways into both the
computer business,
the server,
and ultimately,
and,
and in the printing business,
which was an offshoot of,
of,
of the soda,
that whole approach.
Uh,
so an incremental,
logical,
incremental ism in their strategy.
A strategy that both puts emphasis on
exploitation and on exploration.
One of the problems with companies that
fail is either focused on exploitation.
Let's make the most money we can,
let's not worry about innovation and the
future.
Uh,
or they focused entirely on exploration,
uh,
new ideas,
new technology,
but they don't focus on,
on,
on exploitation,
and therefore their profit margins go
down.
And eventually they are forced to make
decisions that are not,
uh,
not good for them.
Uh,
not good for the long run.
The third element is risk management.
And we've seen that in spades in,
in the,
uh,
two Oh eight,
two Oh nine period,
uh,
with the economic,
with the deepest recession we've had
since the depression,
uh,
firms at a high commitment,
high performance organizations take very
measured risks.
And I'm saying they're not taking risks.
They take measured risks and carefully
considered risks,
some characteristics of them.
For example,
then I found in found Hewlett Packard
southwest airlines.
I just interviewed Gary Kelly,
the CEO of southwest airlines,
and about six,
nine months ago.
Uh,
they,
for example,
they are characterized by very careful
management of debt.
In fact,
HP had no debt ever other than short
term debt.
Uh,
southwest airlines characterized by the
same thing,
uh,
no longterm debt.
In other words,
just to self financing idea here.
Now in some industries,
that's not entirely possible,
but,
but you,
you live as close to that set of ideas
as you can.